oh il y a toujours eu des enfants dans
la vie de pascal et vie mais pendant
longtemps ce n'étaient pas les leurs et
des rebondissements
ils en ont vécu une fausse couche
des problèmes de fertilité leur maison
va devenir un foyer banques mixtes comme
des dizaines d'autres au québec
d'abord familles d'accueil pour un
enfant de la dpj avec possibilité de
l'adopter pointe après tard alors savoir
ce que la vie nous donne et on voulait
pas magasiner non plus dans mon jeu un
petit globe le talent et les yeux bleus
les cheveux blonds trois ans et demi
tenez pied droit a été accrédité puisse
un jour après y'en enfants qui rentrait
chez nous
[Musique]
c'est un enfant d'un an qui arrive chez
eux mais on ne peut ni le montrer ni le
nommer en est heureux on est en amour et
d'ouvrir on est assis comme annoncé sur
wii à ce qu'on oublie un peu les risques
c'est de la bac mix oui parce qu'il tape
ça fait comme un âne et qu'on attend
type le sedin mal c'est là le guide en
eau brute a fait manger des spaghettis
ça mais partout dans la face le risque
de la banque mixte comme le dit pascal
c'est que la famille biologique se
reprenne en main et reprenne ses droits
sur l'enfant
et quand on va aux rencontres
d'information on nous parle de 92%
discus est restée moi quand j'embarque
dans quelque chose que 90% succès mais
j'y crois
la désillusion surviendra après trois
mois de vie commune téléphone a sonné et
puis il faut que vous soyez au centre
jeunesse dans deux heures parce qu'ils
retournent vue avec son père s'est fait
manger puis serait passé à faire puis la
petite toupie c400 morceaux de linge tu
mets ça dans le sac bleu tu pars je peux
pas considérer que notre attachement à
cacher les choses sur cette histoire là
puis je vois toujours le dire puis
pascal dureau la même chose je crois
c'est que ce qu'on a donné à cet enfant
alors tout l'amour qu'on lui a donné ça
lui à partie puis pierce a de plus dans
son petit bailliage de vie mais c'est
sûr que quand tu y es parti moi je
voulais mourir
je voulais mourir le jeune père un frère
le jeu pouvait pas croire qu est ce que
j'avais fait au bon dieu pour mériter ce
[Musique]
la princesse héloïse arrivera seulement
quelques mois plus tard à l'âge de dix
semaines après la descente brutale le
curseur des émotions recommencent à
s'agiter
seul un visage sphère hamas l'a déjà
vécue fait un peu plus par honda mon
désir de mer le stick huawei avait trois
mois le steak sommes mieux que tout ce
que je pouvais imaginer
ah oui
des enfants comme héloïse 145 ont été
placés dans des familles banque mixte à
montréal en 2017 2018 et sur les deux
dernières années seuls trois enfants
sont retournés chez leurs parents
biologiques
dans leur cas il n'y aura aucune visite
supervisée ou non avec les parents
naturels des enjeux de santé mentale la
cocotte une belle cocotte qui est né en
santé a pas de répercussions qui n'a pas
de séquelles qui a pas des est parfaite
parfaite parfaite parfaite par personne
me dit souvent que c'est sûr l'arrêter
dans un grand magasin où il y aurait eu
deux millions d'enfants dans l'approché
choisie meilleure à refaire mais alors
fait que je vide
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le lien familial qu'ils ont
créés ne peut plus être défait depuis
qu'ils sont passés ici à la chambre de
la jeunesse
une adoption qui aura pris 15 mois alors
que pour l'adoption régulière au québec
il faut attendre environ huit ans
d'ailleurs evelyne et pascal s'étaient
inscrits aux signes en 2011 pour
l'adoption régulière et ça devient très
clair que dans leur cas un bonheur
n'arrive jamais seul
[Musique]
enterré wimmenau kokou doit ce minou là
c'est la dernière adoption en date qui
vient compléter le portrait de famille
en a joué l'aider puis on ne tirait les
bons numéros
bah l'avenir nous le dira mais quand
même pour l'instant les bons numéros on
est heureux on est comblé on manque de
sommeil mais on est comblé ici monsieur
prost radio canada montréal